just how we deal with our rubbish has
come a long way around forty four
percent is recycled a fair chunk of the
two hundred million plus tons we
generate every year all councils must
offer a recycling service but only a
small minority of told Sky News they
make it compulsory for households to use
it three rivers counseling heart feature
is one of those which does one of the
things the council has done here is
actually reduced the physical size of
the landfill Finn and I nearly pick it
up once every two week is having a real
impact since 2003 amount of rubbish
being recycled shot up from 18 to 59
percent the council says it's about
educating the public we would certainly
follow up people who were who we thought
were persistently contaminating their
bins with with the wrong start etcetera
and we've encouraged people not to put
recycling for example in their in their
refuse in their land Philbin bye bye
snickering bins local councils decide
that own recycling policy and how often
waste is collected when it comes to
enforcement very few councils have
actually issued fine for recycling
violations instead many choose to
educate households for example in Paris
in mid-wales officials encourage
recycling I only collecting landfill
waste once every three weeks but
lewisham Council in London has a
recycling rate of just 18% one of the
lowest in Britain there we go well done
the Taylor family do their [ __ ] and
wish their area was better it's not
difficult just to get around the garden
waste being it's not it it does take a
bit of time but actually it's quite it's
great doing that other kids because they
were actually learning colors that's why
we've got this system
charity say there needs to be more
joined-up thinking from the government
to help them enforce it I think this is
a role for a blueprint in this country
recycling blueprint were actually every
local authority does a standard thing no
so no matter where you are you're
getting the same materials collected in
the same types of boxes are actually the
colors of the same skies Ocean Rescue
campaign aims to protect the sea from
are discarded rubbish the government
says it is working with local
authorities to do more its target is to
recycle half our waste by 2020 with such
a postcode lottery of recycling there's
plenty of work to do dan whitehead Sky
News